these teams have not seen each other
since the wild card match up in 2019 for
the tampa bay rays it's going to be
left-hander rich hill making his fifth
start of the season
there's a cut and a miss and that is out
number one well that right there is
exactly what you want to see out of
ridge hill
right back ready with the next one and a
wave and a miss
so he takes care of olson on three
pitches it's a one two three first
bottom of the ending coming no score the
lefty sean manaya who after getting
banged up in his first start has really
put together a nice string of outings
there's a ground ball base hit through
the left side
in between andrews and chapman
rosarina is aboard to start this game
for the raise here in the bottom of the
first
off of mania he scrambles after it his
flip to first is in time to get diaz and
let's make sure sean manaya is okay that
was a very hard hit ball
there he goes he's on the move and there
will be
a play but
he is safely in it third that ball
popping away from chapman
rose arena going in head first he's
going to collect himself a little bit
there
2-2 again
and that's lined into center field
ken is there to make the catch the tag
at third or rosarina trots home and the
rays have the first run of this game
well the nice job on the base hit
move up to second a steal of thirds the
sacrifice fly gets the job done
this one's popped up short right
and it's going to be lowry who grabs it
and that will do it so a run for the
raise in the bottom of the first we're
on to the second one nothing tampa bay
in a stretch of 17 consecutive days
where they have a baseball game and
that's a lot a lot of baseball loriano
finds the gap in left center field and
he's gonna have a off double here in the
second inning
runner takes off for third good throws
got to get it he is
out at third base
loriano caught stealing
for the second time this year zanino to
wendell putting the tag on it if you're
gonna attempt it at third base with
nobody out you you it can't even be
close and that really wasn't even that
close
[Music]
got it with a curveball
and murphy he went he's out on strikes
on the curveball
back-to-back strikeout using
that breaking pitch
great pitch there by sean manaya to get
wow looking
good pitch on 3-2 back-to-back
strikeouts for sean manaya
due to pitch hit in the air to right and
hit pretty well piscotty back he's going
to have just enough room and he makes
the catch and that's the three-up
three-dot inning for sean
it's a foul ball will it be playable
boy that's a nice job by zanino
to cover all that ground to get to the
raised dugout and make the catch
and a cutting the miz
he takes care of andres
let's say here's the breaking ball is he
feeling that pitch tonight or what
and that hit him
breaking ball way inside and it hit him
the truck's trying to put the hex on it
reverse jinx there it is ground ball to
third now the throw is going to be to
first and they take care of lowry and
the truck prevails again
we go to the bottom
two-two pitch
good one so joey wendell strikes out
bounced up the middle with the shift on
and
rosarina beats the ship and he has his
second hit
and he chased the same pitch
gets his fourth strikeout remember
margot did a good job of keeping his
hands back on a change up earlier they
might try to spin one
a little pop-up biscotti's got to hustle
in piscotti dies and he caught it
well it saved one run for sure and with
biscotti having to dive if he doesn't
catch it who knows where the ball goes
it may have saved two runs
so terrific play by steven piscotty
it's it's it's under
the velocity is lower
and it's those first two pitches oh
there's a strike
olson didn't like it he thought it was
wide three and two to chapman
a little bit low good take by chapman
murph struck out his first time up he
goes after a fastball and he clocks at
the deep left back on it is meadows at
the wall and it will just
clear the barrier over the yellow stripe
a two-run shot for the a's catcher at a
2-1 oakland lead
a moon shot
at the drop
there's a cutting a miss
fastball maybe a little anger and
frustration behind it gets some swinging
on the ground that's going to get
through the left side
three men over there and he got it
through a two ounce single for mike
zanino and the 357 average climbs
that one's hit well left center field
canna camp canna kemp kemp makes the
catch
that's a big part of the ballpark right
there and tony kemp tracked it down
so tony kemp is gonna be
on base again he's walked and now he's
been hit by a pitch
scored a run in the first oakland two in
the fourth one on one out
now on the fifth and there's a slow
breaking ball strike three call
and a swing and a miss
comes back to get rosa
[Music]
no runs and the swinging to miss the
throw to second base got it
diaz tried to help out wendell he swung
at the pitch i don't know if his hit run
or not
but either way murphy throws him out
he's the sidewinder
that will do it so caught stealing a
couple of strikeouts all good for mania
and a big cut to miss he strikes out
olson that's the first out olson out on
strikes for the third time
and cutting the miss
little cutter there
and he strikes out chapman
10 strikeouts on the night for hill
[Music]
[Applause]
is fast but murphy
another terrific defensive play by
murphy
and he walked him
kemp goes after the first pitch skies
one
joey wendell and it falls
who's covering third and nobody doesn't
matter with two outs alba sanders trying
to score and he's out
very close play at the plate so the a's
are checking with the video room
big call here
so it looked like the right hand got in
before the tag of the hip now it has to
be as we've come to know and love it has
to be extremely extremely clear
oh my goodness
unbelievable that is absolutely
atrocious i don't even know what to say
there's nothing to say bob melvin
[Applause]
comes out and has been ejected
for arguing that call
[Applause]
so lau strikes out
[Music]
got it
so two great innings for you samara
petite six up six down with a couple of
strikeouts
and you're always
you're not always sure exactly where
that's gonna be hey there's a base hit a
rosarena drills it through the left side
one hot lowry throws got him so deekman
gets out of it and the rays do not score
they strand a pair in scoring position
ninth inning coming up
in the air
left field playable for brown
got it and that's the ball game
well the azad has sweat out the eighth
inning and sweat out the ninth inning
but they hang on and
that is a good ball game tonight
from st petersburg